unternehmen die ihre miete nicht zahlen
wollen auch sind zum einen ein ärgernis
auf der anderen seite auch existenz
bedrohen vor allem für kleine vermieter
bild chef julian reichelt ist jetzt bei
mir im studio julian du sprichst mit
einem vermieter und einem mieter ein
großes unternehmen das seine miete nicht
zahlen möchte richtig hier lieber moritz
wir sind jetzt gleich hier bei bild live
verbunden mit patrick zahn dem ceo der
gruppe kick uns allen ein begriff prägt
das deutsche straßenbild kaum eine stadt
in der es keine kik markt gibt diese
märkte sind derzeit geschlossen sowie
große teile unseres landes im moment
geschlossen sind und brach liegen und
wir wollen einmal darüber sprechen wie
es geht wirtschaftlich geht und wie was
ist mit den mietzahlungen von kik offen
auf sich hat aber wir wollen eben auch
darüber sprechen wie kik als unternehmen
direkt betroffen ist von den maßnahmen
und was sie ob patrick taten sich von
der politik wünscht wenn wir nach
österreich schauen dort haben heute zum
beispiel die baumärkte wieder aufgemacht
geschäft von einer gewissen
quadratmeterzahl dürften wieder
aufmachen patrick zahn sie offen
herzlich willkommen hier live bei
bild.de stück unter erkannt schön dass
sie bei uns sind wir haben es schon
gehört bei uns hat sich ein zuschauer
gemeldet frank jürgen schmidt 72 jahre
alt aus bottrop wie kik sozusagen aus
nordrhein-westfalen also man könnte was
sagen ein landsmann von kik und der mann
war dachdeckermeister hat sein leben
lang investiert in immobilien also kein
klassisch reicher mann sozusagen kein
großkonzern keine immobilienfonds
sondern ein typischer deutscher
handwerker der sein leben lang in
immobilien investiert hat und unter
anderem auch vermieter einer
gewerbefläche ist die an die firma kik
vermietet ist und was uns herr schmitz
zu sagen hat und worüber er sich ärgert
das schauen wir uns jetzt einmal an
am vielen sonstigen dritten schrieb mir
die firma kik ein brief der
angehalten war ich dann eine passage
vorlesen im bewerb mit beginn der
behörde entschließung seit mitte märz
die geschäftsgrundlage von mietverträgen
derart gestört ist dass die miete
vollständig zu kürzen ist vor diesem
hintergrund sehen wir uns schweren
herzens auch zu unserem persönlichen
schutz gezwungen zunächst die miete für
den monat april ein zu behalten ohne
weiteren vorankündigungen ohne ein
telefonat oder irgendwie mich mal zu
informieren kann dann dieser brief das
immer verändert hat din a4 seiten
ich möchte jetzt nicht alles gefallen
sind nur mehr stellt sich natürlich die
frage die ich aber noch anwalts mäßig
klären lassen wäre in zukunft wenn die
firma kik schreibt die
geschäftsgrundlage von mietverträgen das
stört ist dass die miete zu kürzen ist
dann bin ich der meinung haben wir
zurzeit einen vertragslosen zustand und
ich kann der firma kik ohne weiteres die
kündigung des ladenlokals zukommen
lassen
herr chan wirtschaftlich keine leichten
zeiten logischerweise auch nicht für kik
was sagen sie herr schmitz ich glaube ja
schmidt ich kann es genau zu der fialen
natürlich nichts sagen aber ich kann
jetzt mit glaube ich kann bestätigen
dass wir über die gesamte mietzeit immer
ein fairer und guter mieter gewesen sind
wir haben im up gründlich unsere mieten
bezahlt ich glaube diese diese ausnahmen
sind situationen
wir sind selber sehr überrascht worden
durch die schließungen die kamen dann
sehr sehr kurzfristig woraufhin wir
diesen brief raus geschickt haben weil
wir alle in der erwartung waren dass es
dann eine gesetzliche regelung dazu
geben wir haben die vor der gesetzlichen
regelungen die es ja jetzt auch gibt
rausgeschickt weil wir gesagt haben wir
haben 2007 104 44 filialen in
deutschland bei ihr für uns gesagt haben
wir halten die miete erst mal zurück um
zu sehen welche gesetzlichen regelungen
es gibt und dann gemeinsam mit dem
vermieter sich sich zusammenzusetzen ich
glaube es ist ganz wichtig zu erkennen
dass der vermieter auch nichts davon hat
wenn die firma kik oder irgendeine
andere firma ich glaube das kann man zu
jedem händler sagen der nicht geöffnet
hat das mit der seine geschäftsgrundlage
verliert das
man gemeinsam eine lösung finden muss
für die zeit in der geschlossen gewesen
ist und darum ging es bei den brief
gemeinsam eine lösung zu finden
und ich glaube ganz wichtig ist eben
auch das wort vorübergehend wir haben
nicht gesagt dass wir definitiv nicht
sagen wir haben mal gesagt bezahlen
vorübergehend nicht und darum gehen dass
um das fest zu fest zu halten bis es
eine gesetzliche regelung geht sind sie
nach ihrer einschätzung auf einem guten
weg zu einer regelung die gemeinsam mit
den vermietern dann stattfinden soll
wir waren auf dem extrem guten weg ich
gebe offen zu
die mediale berichterstattung auch die
politik hat uns da nicht gerade in die
in die karten gespielt weil es war schon
überraschend für uns alle festzustellen
wie plötzlich ich sage auch von dem bis
vor vier wochen waren es noch alles mit
haie und jetzt plötzlich ist der arme
vermieter da waren wir schon überrascht
dass das so ist und wir haben nach
dieser medialen geschichte die das schon
gemerkt dass die fronten verhärtet sind
wir haben insgesamt 2007 filialen in
deutschland europaweit 3098 können sich
vorstellen dass das extrem mühsam ist
dort jede filiale abzuarbeiten
wir sind auf gutem wege wir sind
insbesondere mit dem großvermieter auf
einem sehr sehr guten weg dort lösung zu
finden weil ich glaube eins ist klar und
das gilt für dann schmeckt das gilt für
kik das gilt für aber egal auf wen im
handel
es ist keinem damit geholfen wenn
straßenzüge sterben wenn wenn
innenstädte sterben und ich sage ihnen
ganz ehrlich wenn sie kosten haben und
keine einnahmen dann ist das brutal egal
ob sie groß oder klein sind ob sie eine
filiale haben ob sie 4000 5000 vier
jahren haben der kostenblock bleibt ja
proportional gleich und ich glaube
sowohl für den verbraucher für den
vermieter als auch für den mieter ist
das schlimmste wenn die innenstadt ist
wenn die innenstädte sterben weil wir
sind schon echt anja am limit ich kann
für kik sprechen aber ich weiß von
vielen anderen händlern genauso das ist
eine extrem angespannte situation sie
müssen sich das immer so vorstellen bei
uns wir kaufen unsere ware lange vorab
jetzt kommen die rechnung für die ware
rein das ist unser haupt kostenpunkt das
heißt kurzarbeit mieten ist nur ein teil
der kosten der hauptteil der kosten
liegt in der ware
wir können nicht wie lebensmittel nach
zwei drei wochen im voraus bestellen
sondern wir bestellen sechs bis neun
monate im voraus dass die ware kommt da
mal brutal rein gerauscht
und die rechnung auch und das ist schon
überlebenskampf selbst hören so großes
unternehmen wie kik die rechnung kommen
reingerutscht das ist vermutlich ein
satz den viele menschen in diesem land
gerade sehr nachvollziehen können sie
haben eben die politik erwähnt und auch
das muss man an dieser stelle natürlich
einmal sagen die möglichkeit zur
stundung von mietzahlungen ist ein
gesetz das der bundestag verabschiedet
hat es gibt dafür inzwischen eine
gesetzliche grundlage was erwarten sie
sich von der politik um eben genau das
zu verhindern was sie da eben
beschrieben haben das sterben von ganzen
straßenzügen schließungen von
unternehmen wenn diese maßnahmen dann
hoffentlich bald vorbei sind oder
zumindest gelockert werden österreich
hat heute erste geschäfte wieder
geöffnet was erwarten sie sich von der
deutschen politik ja also ich meine man
muss immer sagen stunden hört sich erst
einmal gut an aber es bleibt er trotzdem
stehen also sie haben trotzdem die
kosten
sie sind da nur aufgeteilt auf mehrere
monate deswegen mein appell auch an die
an die vermieter dass man gemeinsam eine
lösung findet wie kriegt man das
gemeinsam in erstmal die vermieter die
die der wunsch die bitte wie kriegen wir
gemeinsam das problem gelöst ich glaube
kein vermieter ist es geholfen wenn kick
verschwindet oder wenn wer auch immer
verschwindet weil er jetzt einen monat
lang nicht öffnen konnten von der
politik wünsche ich mir etwas mehr
hemdsärmeligkeit und etwas mehr näher zu
den zuzug zu den geschäftsmodellen
wenn man sieht wie lange wir jetzt an
überbrückungskredit arbeiten oder was
ich auch von den kollegen höre das ist
schon extrem mühsam und sie müssen sich
immer vorstellen
der überbrückungskredit der kommt ja
nicht in dem sinne vom staat sie gehen
hat trotzdem über ihre hausbanken und
man muss ehrlicherweise sagen sie haben
natürlich momentan extrem schlechte
karten gegenüber der bank in der
verhandlung weil sie müssen ja ein
überbrückungskredit bekommen das heißt
sie können nicht sagen
dann gehe ich woanders hin oder hole mir
später sondern sie haben extrem
schlechte karten und da würde ich mir
etwas mehr zu den unterschiedlichen
geschäftsmodellen menschen thema
überbrückungskredit bei den banken ein
ganz großes thema im moment erzählen sie
uns kurz von den erfahrungen die sie da
machen wir hören dass banken trotzdem
weiter der sehr penibel sind das geld
was der staat ja im moment tatsächlich
zu 100 prozent garantiert ungern
herausgeben wir hören dass die zinsen
deutlich teilweise deutlich über dem
liegen was die bundesregierung empfohlen
hat also das unternehmen
wie sie zum beispiel dann auch sozusagen
doch für diese krise bestraft werden mit
den krediten überbrückungskrediten die
sie einholen und dann hoch relativ hoch
verzinsen müssen wie es ihre erfahrungen
da im moment mit dem was ja eigentlich
so einfach geschehen sollte also ich
kann ihnen erst mal in keinem wieder
widersprechen ich muss aber auch eine
lanze für die banken brechen uns ja
logischerweise ein risiko ein kredit
herauszugeben und wir haben aus der
bankenkrise hier alle gelernt dass man
schon gut prüfen soll wie man einen
kredit gibt wie man wie man dem wie man
den kredit gibt
deswegen habe ich auch verständnis für
die banken das dort mechanismen laufen
die einfach eingehalten werden müssen
das ist auch richtig so aber nur dieses
dass das sogar ihren der politik dass
sie als unternehmen mal eben zur kfw
gehen und geld bekommen das wird ja in
der in die medien soll suggeriert so
läuft das nicht sind extrem zähe
verhandlungen bei logischerweise die
banken auch unsicherheiten haben
wann wird man wird aufgeschlossen sie
müssen auch sehen kick zum beispiel mode
ist vergänglich nehmen wir das
ostergeschäft als beispiel das ist weg
das ostergeschäft das haben wir einfach
verloren damit ein riesenloch bei kik
aber nicht nur wir sondern sondern viele
andere händler auch und dann die banken
fragezeichen ich kann die fragezeichen
in teilen auch verstehen ich glaube dass
ein geschäftsmodell gekickt sogar nach
der krise gibt da sein wird
nichtsdestotrotz müssen sie darlegen und
klar wenn sie die möglichkeit haben geld
zu verdienen dann werden die banken mit
sicherheit auch gucken dass der dass der
zins oben ist weil sie wissen ja jedes
unternehmen braucht momentan einen oder
fast jedes an ein kredit von daher sind
die karten einfach schlecht und da wurde
ich mir schon wünschen dass die politik
das auch dann zumindest so darstellt und
nicht der breiten masse suggeriert dass
es extrem einfach ist diese kredite zu
kommen und auch hier muss man immer
sagen kredite müssen zurückgezahlt
werden also es ist kein geschenk oder
sonstiges sondern am ende des tages
müssen mit den kredit auch zurückzahlen
das heißt die krise hat für uns schon
extrem wirtschaftlichen schaden
hinterlassen wo wir zwar alles
dransetzen den so klein wie möglich zu
halten das gelingt uns auch eigentlich
ganz gut trotzdem das ist endlich da sie
können nicht endlich ware im laden haben
die bezahlt ist und es kommt kein wunder
an rund 30.000 mitarbeiter sind es
glaube ich die meisten von denen werden
derzeit zu hause sein bei kik das
management geht natürlich nehme an bei
ihnen auch im home office weiter aber
all die mitarbeiter von ihnen die
in den filialen beschäftigt sind haben
wir derzeit nichts zu tun was wünschen
sie sich für die von der politik wie
gesagt noch einmal mit blick nach
österreich wo heute geschäfte bis zu
einer gewissen quadratmeterzahl schon
wieder geöffnet haben was wäre wichtig
für märkte wie kik als regelung der
politik der morgen ansteht
ja also natürlich also normal ich kann
das das gesundheitlich schlecht
abschätzen ich bin kein arzt deswegen
dass gesundheitliche geht geht vor ich
wünsche mir für unsere mitarbeiter dass
wir zur zur normalität zurückfinden das
wir logischerweise schutzmaßnahmen
ergreifen werden wie masken usw
dass das wenn wir unseren unserer
mitarbeiter zur verfügung stellen
wir werden plexiglas die kassen ich
glaube jeder kennt das aus dem
supermarkt moment momentan schon das
werden wir logischerweise auch an
einführen und und machen aber ich
wünsche mir dass wir alle zur normalität
zurückkommen und ich würde mir von der
politik wünschen auf unser 30.000
mitarbeiter das ist irgendwo irgend
einer form steuer steuererleichterungen
hinten raus gibt oder oder oder
sonstiges weil unsere mitarbeiter schon
die sind momentan in kurzarbeit das
heißt sie habe nicht hundert prozent
ihres einkommen da ist eine lücke und
die kosten auch dass nicht alles gerade
eben wirklich gesagt geht das gilt ja
auch für mich für uns für unsere
mitarbeiter die laufen weiter die
rechnung kommen rein und ich wünsche mir
lassen und entlastung für unsere
mitarbeiter weil ich glaube die sind
schon arg gebeutelt wir haben viele
leute die die die auch nach stunden
bezahlt werden die momentan eben nicht
ihre ihre stunden voll machen können und
das ist schon traurig weil ich weiß dass
der große unserer mitarbeiter zumindest
mit denen ich spreche
wir wollen wieder arbeiten die wollen
wieder raus an die an die front und ja
sie haben mir eben gesagt dass ihr
unternehmen nach dieser krise nach ihrer
einschätzung sogar stärker dastehen wird
als vorher was glauben sie wie es da
stehen wird was wären die unterschiede
seien was lernen sie aus dieser krise
wie lässt sich das unternehmen
vielleicht auch transformieren durch
diese kur oder krise die wir so noch nie
erlebt haben ja wir haben also ist
ganz ganz ganz konkret wir haben klein
online shop der wirklich marginal der
macht ungefähr ein prozent des umsatzes
aus dem wir momentan natürlich starke
wachstumsraten
das schauen wir uns nach der krise noch
mal genauer an ich glaube aber dass
durch die krise geschärft und eben durch
die auch gerade im wirtschaftlichen
einbußen die mit sicherheit jeder
irgendwo haben wird es leute geben wird
die die vielleicht erstmalig in kick
reingehen und die dieses unsere preis
leistungs gefüge was wir eben anbieten
wir sind ein sehr preisaggressiver
anbieter ohne bei den beiden qualitäten
abstriche zu machen und ich glaube dass
das viele kunden überzeugen wird
zukünftig bei uns einkaufen zu gehen die
vielleicht vorher nicht bei uns
einkaufen gegangen sind und von daher
glaube ich fest dass das geschäftsmodell
kick nach vorne raus erfolgreich sein
wird und ich kann nur sagen wir sitzen
so eng wie wir momentan im management
zusammen setzen die über alle etagen
nicht englisch sondern in der krisen
meisterung das gibt mir mut dass wir die
richtigen entscheidungen treffen um nach
vorne raus wirklich gut dazustehen
das war patrick chan ceo der firma kik
der uns heute erzählt hat wie es mit dem
unternehmen weiter gehen wird aber auch
wie es mit den mietzahlungen für all die
vermieter der diversen kik filialen im
land weitergehen soll
herten herzlichen dank dass sie heute
live bild waren